Traduttore: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Andrea Giglio
Buongiorno!
Bene, adesso che vi siete presentati,
se volete, mi presento io.
Lo hanno già fatto in parte,
però io voglio dire qualcosa
di più chiaramente.
Sono uno studente di 19 anni
sono nato qui a Trento.
Frequento il primo anno di Studi
Internazionali, qui all’Università.
Studio, perché chiaramente c'è tanto
studiare, intendiamoci...
Però, ho tanti hobby.
Il mio preferito è lo sport,
qualsiasi tipo di sport.
Il migliore direi che…
il mio preferito è la pallavolo.
L'ho praticato per 9 anni,
ad alti livelli.
Adesso, chiaramente,
non ho più il tempo per starci dietro,
detto in parole semplici,
però trovo ancora il tempo
per andare in palestra
e allenare una piccola squadra
di ragazzi under 15.
Il calcio è qualcosa di fondamentale.
La partita del venerdì con gli amici
è qualcosa di sacro.
Non bisogna mancare, voi mi capite vero?
Be’...immaginavo…
E poi qui siamo a Trento,
in mezzo alle montagne,
in mezzo alle Dolomiti,
quindi non amar le montagne
sarebbe un delitto.
E quindi anche la montagna:
vado a fare scalate,
scio, anche sci alpinismo,
insomma mi piace muovermi!
Tutte cose bellissime, no?
C’è un però, un piccolo però,
che per fare tutte
queste cose serve fiato.
E io di fiato non ne ho.
O meglio, ne ho meno.
Perché io ho la fibrosi cistica.
“Cosa è la fibrosi cistica?”,
voi mi chiederete.
La fibrosi cistica è
una malattia genetica.
È una malattia genetica
che compromette in maniera seria
l’apparato digerente e respiratorio.
In pratica, tutte le secrezioni dal corpo,
tutti i liquidi che produciamo
sono più densi e più concentrati.
Il sudore è più salato,
le lacrime sono più dense,
i succhi gastrici.
E c’è una frase, molto importante,
che risale al 1700,
quando ancora c’erano delle osservazioni
empiriche su questa malattia.
“Guai per il bambino che sapora di salato
da un bacio sulla fronte,
perché maledetto e presto deve morire”.
Una condanna senza appello, oseri dire.
Ovviamente le cose sono cambiate,
cioè mi vedete, sono qua a parlare
di fronte a voi,
non sono né deperito, né altro, no?
Sono in forma, dai, ci sta,
concedetemelo, almeno questo.
Ad un certo punto, un nostro amico,
qualche estate fa viene a chiederci:
”Ma vuoi scalare il Kilimangiaro?”
E io dico: “Il Kilimangiaro?
Cos’è il Kilimangiaro? Già ero così alto…”
Ed io ho detto:
”Informiamoci, cos’è questo Kilimangiaro?”
Il Kilimangiaro è la più alta
montagna dell’Africa,
uno strano vulcano in fase di quiescenza,
con tre coni vulcanici.
Alto 5.895 metri, è la montagna
più alta dell’Africa,
il vulcano più alto del mondo,
la montagna singola più alta del mondo
ed una delle Seven Summits del pianeta.
Al che ho detto:
“Io? Fibrosi cistica? Sul Kilimangiaro?
No dai, non prendiamoci in giro”.
Ovviamente la mia famiglia
inizialmente diceva:
“Che cosa ti salta in testa?”
Poi dopo hanno capito,
bisogna far qualcosa,
bisogna andare oltre,
bisogna far cambiare la mentalità.
I medici, non ne parliamo; sono andato
dal mio medico curante e gli ho detto:
“Eh, io vorrei scalare il KIlimangiaro”
“Ah si? Secondo me è meglio invece
che vai sul lido di Jesolo
a prenderti l’aria salubre del mare,
seduto lì, non ti piace?”.
Indovinate come è andata?
Ve l’ho detto prima giustamente, quindi…
E quindi, a febbraio del 2014
siamo sbarcati in Africa,
e l’Africa te la raccontano,
ti dicono tante cose, però,
fino a quando non ci arrivi,
non sai veramente come è.
I primi giorni, abbiamo camminato tanto
in mezzo agli animali della savana,
in mezzo alla giungla.
Non vi dico altro;
durante la nostra attraversata
della giungla c’era una pioggia battente.
99% di umidità, il fango sotto,
la pioggia sopra... insomma un disastro.
Però mano a mano, camminando,
siamo arrivati fin quasi in cima
a 3.008 al primo rifugio,
poi a 4.008 al secondo rifugio
e volevamo dare l'assalto alla cima.
E la notte dell’assalto alla cima
è stata una cosa pazzesca.
Sveglia a mezzanotte, per arrivare in cima
alle sei di mattina in una nebbia padana,
cioè sembrava di essere allo svincolo
della A4, mi sono trovato lì...
E questo cartello verde che diceva:
“Congratulazioni, sei arrivato
in cima al Kilimangiaro”.
E lì ho pianto, lo ammetto,
è un sentimento umano.
E poi la discesa,
mi aspettavano altre 11 ore per arrivare
al rifugio dove avremmo dormito.
Fate conto, partenza a mezzanotte,
arrivo al rifugio alle 17.
17 ore di camminata al netto.
Ed è andata così!
Perché tutto questo è stato possibile?
Voglio dire, eravamo rimasti al bambino
che sapeva di salato,
che presto doveva morire
e adesso mandiamo un ragazzo malato
di fibrosi cistica sul Kilimangiaro.
La ricerca ha fatto passi da gigante.
Nel 1989, che clinicamente parlando
è l'altro ieri,
hanno scoperto la proteina
causa della fibrosi cistica: la CFTR.
Questa proteina sostanzialmente è zoppa,
nel senso che non permette
al corpo di funzionare bene.
Ora, un piccolo inciso su quella
che è la ricerca: cosa è la ricerca?
Ci sono tre tipi di ricerca:
la prima che potremmo chiamare
“terapia genica”,
come molti l’hanno definita,
ha alimentato tante speranze
per quanto riguarda la fibrosi cistica
ma le ha deluse.
La seconda è quella
che ci immaginiamo tutti:
lo scienziato pazzo, con i fumi,
gli alambicchi,
questi diversi liquidi colorati,
insomma quello che ci immaginiamo tutti.
E poi c’è una terza figura, figlia
di quello che è il progresso scientifico.
Io lo chiamo “scienziato-metereologo”;
perché il metereologo guarda le correnti,
le nubi, in pratica ci da un'idea
di come sarà la giornata
da qui a molto tempo,
anche una settimana, due settimane.
In pratica lo “scienziato-metereologo”
fa la stessa cosa con la cellula.
Dice: “Se la cellula sottoposta ad un dato
trattamento reagisce in questo modo
è plausibile che ci siano
tutta una serie di conseguenze”.
In pratica da allo scienziato “pazzo”
qualche cosa di concreto su cui lavorare.
Non andare a tentoni,
o come diciamo noi Trentini, “a taston”,
fino a come poteva essere 10 o 20 anni fa.
Questo ha permesso alla ricerca medica
di raggiungere livelli
che fino a neanche 3-4 anni fa
sarebbero stati possibili.
Per la prima volta, è stato scoperto,
è stato prodotto, diciamo,
un mix vitaminico apposta
per la fibrosi cistica.
Adesso la ricerca medico-scientifica
si sta concentrando sugli antibiotici,
non più in vena per 3-4 ore,
attaccati ad un letto,
ma semplicemente inalnado
un piccolo “puff”, sostanzialmente.
Quello che vorrei dirvi oggi è che,
il coraggio di osare, è anche questo;
è l’abbattere il limite.
Oggi si giocano i giochi importanti,
passatemi la ripetizione.
Oggi, per la prima volta
nella storia dell'uomo,
abbiamo la possibilità di battere
la malattia genetica in assoluto
più diffusa al mondo.
È una sfida di fronte alla quale
non ci possiamo tirare indietro.
No, signori!
E questa è una sfida molto più alta
della scalata al Kilimagiaro.
La ricerca costa fatica soprattutto.
Siete con me, siamo tutti insieme,
proiettati verso questa ricerca
medico-scientifica?
(Sì.)
Allora arriveremo molto presto
ad una soluzione.
Grazie!
(Applausi)